Bernie Sanders gave an interview on
MSNBC which was for a few hours
considered a blockbuster he seemed to be
saying that his campaign was effectively
done although he wasn't officially
ending it Bernie Sanders said that he
would vote for Hillary Clinton in
November and he said the top priority
which we've also agreed is the top
priority is stopping Donald Trump in
November here is Bernie Sanders on MSNBC
going viral instantly people going
completely crazy decision turning back
to our country set broiling politics are
you going to vote for Hillary Clinton in
November yes yeah I think the issue
right here is I'm going to do everything
I can to defeat Donald Trump right I
think Trump in so many ways will be a
disaster for this country if you would
have be elected president we do not need
a president whose cornerstone of his
campaign is his bigotry is insulting the
Mexicans and Latinos and and this went
viral he didn't say well my priority is
being the nominee he actually said yes
I'm going to vote for Hillary Clinton
this exploded an hour later Bernie
Sanders was on CNN and he used what some
people are calling noticeably different
language about whether he would vote for
Hillary Clinton the answer was no longer
yes take a look at the interview from an
hour later we look forward to doing it
going forward first let's deal with some
specific political housecleaning and
then we'll get to breaks it will get to
the implications right no endorsement of
Hillary Clinton simply stated when the
day comes in November and Sanders has to
cast his vote to whom does it go and
what likely it will go to Hillary
Clinton when you say in all likelihood
what percentage of margin of error I
don't want it poss words here here's
where we are right now Chris Lee's yeah
I want I believe this country faces
enormous crises I believe how politics
and our economics are dominated by big
money interests I believe the Democratic
Party has got to become the party of
working people so first interview MSNBC
will you vote for Hillary Clinton in
November yes second interview CNN will
you vote for Hillary Clinton in all
likelihood yeah
was this because of blowback after the
first segment earlier in the day Bernie
supporters online were going apoplastic
Louis I received a ton of tweets and
emails all sorts of stuff from them
saying this is not over Bernie Sanders
won California he's taking it to the
convention Hillary's getting indicted
etcetera etcetera uh it's not clear even
Bernie Sanders thinks that at this point
and you know what that's okay that's
okay the big picture is that the
semantic difference between yes I'm
voting for Hillary Clinton and in all
likelihood I'm voting for Hillary
Clinton doesn't really matter because
back in May of 2015 not May of 2060 not
this past May last May of 2015 Bernie
Sanders said he would support the
Democratic nominee here is a transcript
from an ABC News interview with George
Stephanopoulos from a third George
Stephanopoulos said if you lose in this
nomination fight will you support the
Democratic nominee yes I have in the
past Stephanopoulos falling up following
up not going to run as an independent
Sanders no absolutely not I've been very
clear about that I think this is much
ado about nothing Louis it is very very
clear that Hillary Clinton is going to
be the Democratic nominee uh yet you can
throw scenarios at me of what if she
gets indicted in blah blah blah blah
blah I don't believe that that is going
to happen this blew up and i truly don't
get why and I don't even see any any
practical operational difference between
what Bernie Sanders said on MSNBC and an
hour later on CNN let's disclose again
that were both Bernie fans right both
wanted Bernie to win this thing yes
because now I have to say this is this
going to be the nail in the coffin for
the Bernie fanatics uh well I don't know
because even after Bernie Sanders said
he was voting for Hillary Clinton I was
getting emails from people saying Bernie
will be the nominee I don't know AJ
Goodman who we interviewed very recently
said he heard something about Hillary's
getting indicted any day and Bernie's
going to be the nominee although a step
further I don't know that if Hilary gets
indicted and drops out which is not
happening I don't even know that Bernie
gets the nomination then I think in that
case there will be some kind of of of
decision made it's not going to by
default go to Bernie Sanders I'm not
saying that's a good
I'm saying I think even if Hilary gets
indicted uh post convention and we're
running out of time for it to happen
pre-convention I still don't know that
Bernie Sanders gets the nomination call
me crazy well if even Bernie Sanders
realizes that he's not going to be the
nominee yeah maybe the only reason he is
still in this is because there is
something looming that might mean
pre-convention well that's the
conspiratorial approach the other side
is he he wants to be officially ended
until the convention and rightly so so
that he can try to negotiate elements of
his his platform to move Hillary Clinton
to the left which I completely respect
well maybe yeah but um the can even
successfully do that uh you know we just
heard her speak not too long ago she
seems to be having she seems to have all
the right talking points for being far
left uh right now and it just well
that's ridiculous